[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la médecine a beaucoup évolué on vit
beaucoup plus vieux mais pour autant est
ce qu'on vit mieux je m'appelle sahara
je suis médecin généraliste et gériatres
alors la gériatrie qu'est ce que c'est
c'est la médecine qui s'occupe des gens
âgés comme à l'opposé la pédiatrie la
médecine qui s'occupe des enfants
à chaque fois que j'explique mon métier
j'ai toujours les mêmes retour soit les
gens ne connaissent pas soit on me
demande avec compassion à quel point
c'est difficile ton métier mais je vous
rassure j'ai un métier passionnant pour
que vous compreniez un petit peu mieux
mon métier je vais vous raconter une
petite histoire cette histoire c'est
l'histoire de robert robert à 80 ans il
vit chez lui il est tombé
malheureusement et il s'est cassé le col
du fémur
le col du fémur c'est le haut du fémur
au ce qui situe ici et le col est ici et
sur la radio graphique vous voyez si
vous voyez peut-être sur votre gauche
un col du fémur qui est ce qui est cassé
si vous ne le voyez pas je pourrais vous
donner un petit cours de radiographie
tout à l'heure
donc il s'est cassé le col du fémur
qu'est ce qui s'est passé il a été
emmené par les pompiers de chez lui
jusqu'à l'hôpital et ensuite une fois à
l'hôpital il a été opéré par les
chirurgiens orthopédistes
ensuite il a été admis en gériatrie et
en gériatrie on s'en est occupé alors
qu'est ce qu'on a fait mais déjà on a
essayé de comprendre pourquoi est-ce
qu'il a chuté pourquoi est ce qu'il est
tombé chez lui robert peut-être que
c'était une raison bête un tapis mal
positionné ou alors un meuble qui gêne
est peut-être que ces lunettes ne sont
plus à sa vue ou peut-être qu'il a pris
trop de médicaments pour bien dormir le
soir et ça malheureusement ça fait
chuter on va aussi essayer de comprendre
pourquoi est-ce qui s'est cassé le col
du fémur parce que finalement on peut
tomber mais c'est pas pour autant qu'on
se casse tout le temps le col du fémur
donc on va
s'intéresser à son alimentation
peut-être qu'il est dénutri ça veut dire
que comme pas mal de gens âgés ils
mangent qu'une seule soupe au dîner et
ça c'est pas assez
c'est pas assez pourquoi parce qu'il ya
pas assez de protéines dans la soupe
les protéines ça fait le muscle le
muscle il est attaché sur l'os et quand
il se contracte
il stimule les cellules osseuses pour
qu'elle soit en bonne santé et que votre
os soit rigide et ne se casse pas quand
vous allez tomber
on va aussi s'intéresser aux facteurs de
risque d'ostéoporose
peut-être que justement l'ostéoporose
pour vous explique c'est une maladie du
squelette aux ce qui fait que votre os
est beaucoup plus fragile et donc va se
casser plus facilement peut-être qu'ils
présentaient des facteurs de risque
d'ostéoporose et ensuite en gériatrie
on va s'occuper d'autre chose que vous
compreniez la différence avec les autres
spécialités médicales
quand vous avez un problème
cardiologique vous allez voir un
cardiologue
quand vous avez un problème digestif
vous allez voir un gastroentérologue en
gériatrie
on va s'occuper tout globalement on va
s'intéresser à tous et ce que robert
peut-être sur le plan neurologique
présente déjà des troubles cognitifs ou
un problème cardiaque pulmonaire ou une
infection qui font qu'il hâte qu'il est
tombé aussi donc finalement suite à
cette hospitalisation
on va faire le point sur l'état de santé
de robert et c'est de comprendre
pourquoi il est tombé et pourquoi il
s'est cassé le col du fémur
ensuite on va pouvoir lui donner des
recommandations afin qu'il rentre chez
lui mais s'il rentre chez lui parce que
la chute
c'est le premier motif d'hospitalisation
quand on est âgé et c'est gravissime de
ce cassé le col du fémur
parce qu'il faut savoir que 30 % des
gens qui vont se cassé le col du fémur
vont décéder dans l'année des suites des
complications de cette fracture
donc c'est gravissime et moi ça me
touche ça me touche personnellement
parce que moi dérobert j'en vois tous
les jours
j'en vois tous les jours qui viennent
pour les mêmes raisons et quand on fait
notre bilan médical on trouve les mêmes
causes les mêmes raisons alors tout ça
peut-être que ça aurait pu être évité
mais comment peut-être par la médecine
préventive la médecine préventive c'est
quoi peut-être que vous voyez à la
télévision manger cinq fruits et légumes
par jour
ça c'est une très bonne recommandation
bonnes recommandations parce qu'il faut
manger des fruits et légumes et que
c'est bon pour la santé
on sait que ça diminue l'apparition de
nombreuses maladies et donc c'est très
intéressant pour la population en
général
mais pour quelques personnes ça va être
une catastrophe
pourquoi parce qu'ils vont très mal
toléré ces fruits et légumes et vont
être sur l'étoile est toute la journée
avec de gros troubles digestifs et ça
c'est pas drôle vous voyez aussi fait
une activité physique régulièrement 30
minutes par jour
ça aussi c'est une excellente
recommandations on sait que
scientifiquement faire 30 minutes
d'activité par jour ça diminue
l'apparition de nombreuses maladies et
donc de ce fait ça diminue la mortalité
donc c'est une très bonne recommandation
mais quand on est obèse et quand on a
mal au genou
est ce que vous pensez que faire juste
trente minutes de marche par jour c'est
facile
ben non c'est pas facile donc la
médecine préventive elle est
intéressante si elle est individualisé
et personnalisé comme ça on peut donner
des recommandations spécifiques pour que
vous compreniez un petit peu mieux
j'avais robert 80 ans qui est tombé chez
lui qui s'est cassé le col du fémur
on va faire un bond en arrière un bond
dans le passé quinze ans avant robert à
65 ans il est jeune retraité il vient
nous voir pour une consultation de
médecine préventive
ils souhaitent vieillir en bonne santé
alors qu'est ce qu'on va pouvoir lui
proposait déjà
on va s'intéresser à sa vie passée
qu'est ce qu'il a fait comme travail
est-ce qu'il était derrière un
ordinateur assez sédentaires ou est-ce
qu'ils avaient un travail physique
est-ce qu'il était stressé dans son
travail ou est ce que il était stressé
dans sa vie personnelle privée
est-ce qu'il a eu des maladies pendant
toute sa vie parce que tout ça ça nous
donne des indices et lors du jour de la
consultation au tenté avec robert on va
pouvoir faire un point complet un check
up médical complet pour vérifier si tout
va bien sur le plan neurologique
cardiologique pulmonaire digestif et si
besoin on fera des examens
complémentaires pour voir où on en est
des radiographies peut-être une
ostéodensitométrie osseuse
parce que peut-être que déjà la 65 ans
on pourra avoir que le squelette de
robert est fragile et que peut-être
quinze ans après il présentera cette
fracture du col du fémur
on pourra aussi faire des analyses
biologiques analyses biologiques qui
peut être reviendront normal puisque ce
sont des analyses biologiques classique
donc comme ça finalement sur de la
médecine occidentale classique on
pourrait se dire que tout va bien et que
robert est en bonne santé mais en fait
on peut peut-être aller plus loin ça
veut dire qu'on peut s'intéresser à des
petits symptômes qui ennuie robert mais
qui pour la médecine classique ne
dérange en rien et pour nous nous disent
qu'il est pas malade
c'est à dire peut-être qu'ils présentent
des réveils nocturnes toutes les nuits à
3 heures du matin peut-être qu'il a des
diarrhées régulièrement mais qu'en fait
les gastro-entérologues ou vérifier que
tout va bien et on va pouvoir faire des
analyses biologiques précise très
spécifique pour vérifier par exemple si
au niveau des neurones ça fonctionne
bien ça veut dire que si un neurone
communique bien avec l'autre grâce à des
bons taux de dopamine noradrénaline
sérotonine vérifier peut-être sur des
analyses très précise qu'il n'y a pas
encore de carences vitaminiques de
minéraux de choses dont on n'a pas
l'habitude de mesurer d'habitude on
pourra aussi s'intéresser à son
microbiote intestinal le microbiote
intestinal vous en entendez parler
régulièrement comme étant le deuxième
cerveau je pense dans le futur vous en
entendrez parler comme le premier
cerveau donc robert est venu on a fait
une consultation de médecine préventive
qui est vraiment complète et ensuite on
va pouvoir donner un plan d'action à
robert
qu'est ce qu'on va pouvoir changer chez
lui pour qu'il vive et vieillissant
bonne santé qu'est ce qu'on peut lui
apporter comme élément pour choisir son
activité physique pour choisir son
alimentation
qu'est-ce qu'il peut prendre comme
traitement et aussi ne pas prendre
on va donner ce plan d'action à robert
et robert on le reverra régulièrement à
3 mois à 6 mois à 1 an à deux ans et
peut-être que robert présentera des
problématiques médicales pendant le
temps où on le suit mais on ré adaptera
notre prise en charge comme ça ça paraît
intéressant c'est pas si simple
c'est pas si simple parce que finalement
cette médecine préventive elle n'est pas
enseigné en faculté de médecine ou très
peu aussi parce qu'il n'y a que quelques
centres publics qui la met en place où
quelques médecins qui sortent des
sentiers battus aussi parce que cette
consultation à les longues et puis tous
les éléments biologiques qu'on envoie et
cette prise en charge elle coûte cher
alors je me pose une question vous avez
tous peut-être chez vous ou dans votre
entourage familial une voiture voiture
que vous entretenez régulièrement vous
l'emmenez faire la révision des 20000
vous l'emmenez faire la vidange vérifier
les niveaux et vous même vous gonfler
les pneus tout ça pour quoi
pour vérifier qu'elles fonctionnent bien
et surtout qu'elle ne va pas tomber en
panne et vous êtes
méticuleux parce que vous faites remplir
par votre garagiste avec des coups de
tampons votre carnet d'entretien de
votre véhicule
mais vous aviez un carnet d'entretien
vous aussi c'était le carnet de santé
alors je ne sais pas pour vous mais pour
moi mon carnet de santé je ne sais plus
où il est et ce qu'il serait pas
légitime de se dire qu'il serait
intéressant d'avoir un carnet
d'entretien qui seraient régulièrement
remplis par un médecin qui vérifierait
qu'on est en bonne santé pour pouvoir
rester en bonne santé
à l'heure actuelle on se situe dans une
phase démographique qui s'appelle le
papy boom
tous les enfants qui étaient nés après
la deuxième guerre mondiale représentait
le baby boom et ses enfants ont vieilli
donc sont dans le papy boom et dans les
10 20 ans à venir
la population va être extrêmement
vieillissante alors je vous ai parlé de
robert et sa fracture du col du fémur
mais finalement j'aurais pu vous parler
de robert et son hypertension artérielle
ou robert et son accident vasculaire
cérébral ou robert et sa maladie
chronique et son diabète ou sa maladie
neurodégénérative pourquoi mais parce
que tout ça ça entraîne de la dépendance
et du handicap
alors d'après les études scientifiques
oui on vit plus vieux mais on ne vit pas
mieux alors comme le disait john
fitzgerald kennedy est ce qu'il serait
pas intéressant de rajouter de la vie
aux années plutôt que des années à la
vie
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]